I think it was one of the most
incompetent lead run deals I've ever
seen a hundred and fifty billion dollars
given we got nothing we got nothing
they got a path to nuclear weapons very
quickly it's a very bad deal I'm not
saying anything different tonight that I
have been saying for two years ago it's
a horrible horrible embarrassment to our
country out of weakness when actually we
had great strength all right that was
the president from our exclusive
interview earlier this week talking
about the disastrous Iran nuclear deal
now of course I was put in place by the
Obama administration earlier today the
president he did announce he will not
recertify that deal and here is what he
said while the United States adheres to
our commitment under the deal the
Iranian regime continues to fuel
conflict terror and turmoil throughout
the Middle East and Beyond importantly
Iran is not living up to the spirit of
the deal I am announcing today that we
cannot and will not make this
certification finally standing up to the
mullahs and Iran the radical mullahs and
stopping this insanity of trying to
bribe them to be part of the world
community also another big story we are
watching tonight and NFL spokesman says
when team owners meet next week the
league is not going to put players or
make them stand for the anthem he said
quote what we don't want have is a
proposal that changes our policy we
don't have something that mandates
anything that's clear it was reaction to
both these stories we have the author of
defeating jihad the make America great
again coalition chief strategist and
former deputy assistant to the president
Sebastian Gorka and civil rights
attorney Darryl parks good to see you
both Darryl parks we're watching what's
happening unfold with North Korea
Bill Clinton announced the American
people there's a good deal for the
American people that's after he tried to
bribe Kim jong-un's father Kim jong-il
with billions of taxpayer dollars in
energy so bribing dictators didn't work
then now Obama ups the ante he's trying
to bribe the Mosin Iran with a hundred
and fifty plus billion dollar
and finally this president said you know
what we're not going to try and bribe
you knowing that you're not going to
keep your side of the deal anyway
is it a time America stop the policy is
of appeasement aren't you proud of the
president that I well you know I think
the president needs to look at it I
think we need to be concerned about Iran
the deal was a deal that certainly
needed some scrutiny I think you ran a
hundred and fifty billion dollars is a
good idea well without question now my
understanding that this money was money
that they were going to get anyway it
wasn't like we gave them money so I
think that money wasn't really our money
though well worth it then why would you
give a rogue regime let me play on the
screen by the way I got it right now
Iranians burning American flags Iranians
burning Israeli flags chanting death to
America death to Israel let's put it up
on the screen so that our entire
audience can see this here yeah okay
burning our president in effigy and and
so on and so forth
death to America chanted by the crowds
death to Israel really why would he ever
give them a penny dr. Gorka why would he
give them one cent look this is a
theocratic dictatorship since 1979 Sean
this has been a dictatorship why would
you have any deal with a dictatorship
and give them money to make their
dictatorship stronger it didn't work in
1938 with Hitler it didn't work with the
Soviet Union when we signed a chemical
weapons ban with them they broke that
band before the ink was dry on the
treaty and it's not going to work with
Iran look what's happened since then
they've escalated their involvement
they've been destabilizing the whole
Middle East and as you said this is a
nation that every Friday in the mosque
calls for our destruction the jcpoa made
them more powerful thanks to president
obama thanks to people like Colin Carr
thanks to Ben Rhodes this is now a dead
man walking thanks to President Trump
because the deal has to have a stake
driven
it's hard no I agree and listen I think
it's proven in North Korea the policies
of appeasement didn't work for neverold
Chamberlain there wasn't peace in our
time it didn't work for for Obama didn't
work for Jimmy Carter it didn't work for
Bill Clinton and this time standing up
to evil in our time is the only answer
all right let me move on to the NFL we
don't have a proposal that changes
policy we don't have something that
mandates anything that's clear NFL
spokesman Joe Lockhart used to be
Clinton spokesperson really so the NFL
is going to continue this they're going
to take a knee
Darryl parks what do you think the
American people are going to say to that
if this continues well I think the
American people are ready to move
forward and move past this issue Sean I
think the point is you mate we need to
find a plan forward though that put
something in place to address the issues
that the players and many people in the
country are concerned about so I like
many other football fans already to
watch football I think we see the need
and the issue that you know wasn't
presented the issues a good Roderick the
NFL is is full of hypocrites let's be
honest here if you can't put a sticker
on the Dallas Cowboys helmet after they
assassinate police officers doctor Gorka
if you can on the 15th anniversary of
9/11 no one put the date and never again
on there but you're gonna allow these
players to take a knee and and protest
the National Anthem
you know what the NFL is just a bunch of
hypocrites and no wonder they're losing
in ratings and revenue and advertisers
nobody wants to watch this and yet they
don't have the courage to enforce their
own rules
sure the the NFL is committing slow
political suicide that's what they're
doing the president always gets it right
when he goes with his instincts he went
with his instincts on killing the Iran
deal he's going with his instincts on
the flag on the NFL on the anthem why
because he's like he may be a
billionaire and the most powerful man in
the world but he's an American like us
and he knows Americans want people to
respect the flag they love our troops
and they want to respect the national
anthem if the NFL
wants to double down they will pay the
price because the majority of Americans
are not behind them and market forces
will dictate this is political and
economic suicide NFL but if you want to
dull sound if you want to double down go
do it
terrible if the anthem and the flag
doesn't unite is what will right shun we
haven't heard from the president one
solution about dealing with the iniquity
issue that these players are presented
if if the flag that people died fighting
under if that doesn't bring us together
tell me what will what will was shunned
that's the problem we have plenty of
african-american flight for the flag but
they don't get equality that's the point
Errol that's a probably need to address
we got to end it there thank you both
all right when we come